bella tutti ragazzi minuti a questo
nuovo episodio incredibile via mondiale
oggi vedete una partita perfetta da
impostare un avete idea di quanto sia
sono capitato con mike scioscia
abbiamo fatto una strage la strage
abbiamo fatto incredibile buona visione
ragazzi perché è un video pazzesco
lasciate light è un commento poi perché
ci tengo e li guardo tutti
let's go mamma mia che partita raga
questo ce la dobbiamo giocare basta mi
sono rotto questa ce la giochiamo subito
subito mi metto qui faccio finta di
pregare la task 42 vado a fare due però
se per ammazzare step subito a raga
questo è difficile questo è difficile
perché siamo tutti qua secondo me i
ragazzi qua ce la dobbiamo giocare su
penso robe del genere ce la dobbiamo
giocare beni su pence perché io dovrei
ammazzare qualcuno prende subito lenza
perché la gente non riesce a capire che
cacchio famiglia vanno agli altri quando
lo posso ammazzare ma te perché mi ha
appena visto electrical e subito dance
buona vagliata cliccare sono stupido
vagliata cliccare volevo cliccare venzo
cliccato report sono stupido admin nulla
storage niente ma riesce
non lo so non lo so in ordine comunque
riparliamo in albi maggior ragione
allora dire quello che vediamo state
finiti fa dell'ordine cazzo è andata
bene perché ho sbagliato a cliccare mi è
andata ancora bene clickare vance erano
cliccato benz sono veramente un pirla ma
possa essere cosi pirla
tix lights non vede nessuno niente o che
andiamo a fissare le luci o ancora 16 di
call da un secondo me i ragazzi se
giochiamo bene io e mike si può vincere
minchia rapporto la porta ci sta ci sta
se faccio finta di cercare shield
secondo me se arrivava un altro era
ancora meglio però vabbè electrical
admin caffetteria
non lo so skip questa si può vincere la
gara questa si può vincere questa si può
vincerlo e dai mai forza mike reaktor
meltdown 17 per me ce la si può fare
dobbiamo veramente molto seria mike io
farei fuori non so chi è ancora vivo
credo step con holst e formarci rapita e
credono che si può anche non ucciderlo
perché non mi sembra così si power
quindi adesso niente io fine faccio
vitale per finito le tasche vado in
security che c'è baby cesca magari
l'ammazzo o non ammazzano l'ammazzo
perché se la mazza rischio
la tengo qua ok
speriamo anche speriamo che voti non ci
hanno capito e che speriamo che votino
gianpi tech tutti hanno votato gianpi
techno spetta e gianpi tecnico
[Musica]
dell'impostore altrimenti per la colla è
fatta uno basta uccidere nessuno basta
verso il basso ucciderne uno ragazza
uccidendo i notai cacchio dai mai bravo
che il fatto che io l'ho visto la farà
tasco ma non è stato così
compass mi difendo scusa ci sono tre
cavi ne ho fatto uno non fare la barra
saliva e tutti e tre
no quello che ho visto e non sai una
cosa
posso dire una cosa io posso è una cosa
ma esce sempre impostare e basta va bene
allora proviamo a vedere mai entrare qui
dentro c'è sempre la prima chiesa mi
fanno l'opposto bene grazie
debbo dire forte di un attimo matteo è
morto dei cer e caffetteria
marc marquez non lo so nulla
med mark scandalosi nel foglio
[Risate]
no ragazzi accusa insensata ma perché ci
fidiamo degli altri ma io pure tutto
contento aveva anche una cosa ma cosa ma
che gioco è infatti impossibile
va beh secondo me era carina come cosa
secondo me io non avrei mai votato
marchio vabbè ma chi se ne frega
cavolo spero che gli altri facciano le
tasche che marina de martino che notano
la moglie così io non vado mai nelle
emergency e vediamo se non è una grande
etica per gli altri milioni come
capitale emergency però effettivamente
se ci vanno già in mille per nulla fare
nulla non lo so emerge ecco farmi voti
vale adesso aumenti perché meno mi hanno
guardata
ragazze e ragazzi l'ha visto del monito
la nella sala della fifa star bene ma
cos'è
mi piace questa cosa perché siamo i
migliori ma io me li immagino sembrerà
sansa che poi si picchiano fiscale che
si picchiano fortissimo adesso immagino
fioretina le testate a step mentre sta
ancora giocando bene un camper
incredibile lecce sempre in forma che
imposti c'e in posticipo ha finito le
tasche no ce l'ho ancora una che stai
seguiti però va bene perché seguiti
vicino i segreti riguardo dalle camere
quindi perfetto faccio queste vado
subito a fare le emergenze ok la fai la
cosa fa a nino cosa panino che si mette
a fare qua la task mentre c'è il coso
zuma è pazzo
nino pazzo raga devi cesca velocità
siamo vicine mi dice che vuole uccidere
i pro ciechi impostore che non è il
fortore attenzione di cesca vado via
vado via
ok mai che sei cascato un po ad ottobre
senza ma non succede ma se si amano ma
nessuno da solo forchetta persone giuste
qualcuno ha detto che non solo mostra
evento si va via via via fuori dalle
balle
un atto che non c'è nessun addio e molto
note ma appena appena appena nata ma hai
hai hai hai mai che mai che mai che mai
che mai che mai che mai e mai e mai che
perché io ho visto che sta là ho visto
che stava mai mai e mai che chiamate
l'emergency chiamate l'emergency e mike
no secco no no no
no sempre sapere nessuno poverino
energetico rivolgersi si può fare
lemergenza cell emergency no perché io
vi vedo mai cry e mike e mike scioscia
maledizione ok via l'emergency viale
emergency
no no va bene lo stesso anzi ma dai
crack mai mamma
[Applauso]
che sia grande il mio papino parlo io no
ma nel cervello cosa fai da te ne sei
uscito come secondo il primo round mark
ai ragazzi che sta nelle partite di oggi
diamo un gas molto molto belle questo mi
sono piaciuto un sacco per ragazzi che
seguiate anche i prossimi episodi ci
sono alcune partite vecchiotte che ho
registrato che troppo usciranno sempre
carina però man mano mi sto squillando
ovviamente sempre di più bravi sia
piaciuto ragazzi iscrivetevi al canale
se lasciato commento qua sotto perché
comunque leggo le vostre opinioni
allora come sempre ci rivediamo ad un
prossimo vito bella ragazzi
[Musica]